الألمان أناس رائعون ليس أنا فقط
أعني الألمان الطبيعيين كشعب
الحكومة الألمانية الألمانية
الدولة عادلة
الأكثر روعة في الطريقة التي يتصرفون بها
هذا الوضع ، ليس فقط في أي شيء
بلد من العالم لا حيث لم نواجه
في البداية مع مثل هذه الصعوبات
القيود ومثل هذه المحاولات لمنع
نذهب على الهواء حتى لا تزال وربما الدردشة
يبدو أنيقًا جدًا بالنسبة لنا
لا يبدو على الإطلاق حالما نحن
ذهبوا على الهواء منعوا بالفعل لدينا
قناة يوتيوب جديدة ولكن لا أستطيع أن أقول
لقد فوجئنا ، ما زلنا نذهب إلى بيرو
قائمة الانتظار ليست على موقع يوتيوب ، ذهبنا على الهواء كما
قناة تلفزيونية كبيرة حقيقية ولدينا
البث متاح على الهواء وعلى الموقع و
دعونا نرى ماذا سيكونون في التطبيق
للقيام بالمزيد فيما يستيقظون
احترام حرية التعبير
أشك كثيرا
لكن في ذلك
الشعب الألماني الجمهور الذي سيرى
مثلهم مملوكًا بشكل أساسي
من قبل الأمريكيين ما يسمى بوسائل الإعلام الألمانية
الغش لسنوات وعقود
الجمهور هو أن الناس سيقدرون ذلك و
قل حقيقة مختلفة
الحقيقة الحقيقية هنا في هذا أنا فقط لا
انا اشك
[موسيقى]